we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P we've been playing a
lot of nice positive voicemails lately
here's just an old-fashioned person who
doesn't like the show
you guys show us disgusting and I see
how I see why David Pac-Man has a such a
big mouth that's how he got his last
name Pac-Man right have a good day
is that a a Pac-Man video game joke or
something like that
uh
uh I don't know not exactly electrifying
Us in terms of the delivery button all
right I guess uh
I appreciate the voicemail and uh okay
bonus show today
it's gonna be fantastic producer Pat
will join me
Don Lemon
says he was fired by CNN
Don Lemon says CNN didn't even try to
communicate with him directly they told
him through his agent CNN says we
actually did try to meet with them
uh what's going on and how does this
relate to the Tucker Carlson firing and
what else is going to happen secondly
the Vegas to California bullet train
which we've talked about before very
strongly now has bipartisan support will
it happen
will people say it's a waste of money
well of course they will and lastly the
Supreme Court is going to decide
can public officials block people who
criticize them on social media or is it
in some sense a violation of the First
Amendment it's an interesting case with
far-reaching implications all of those
stories and more will be on today's
bonus show David Pacman does not have a
soul he doesn't have a soul okay
okay but it will be on the bonus show
that I can tell you you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code indicted for a discount and you can
use the coupon code indicated for an
even larger discount we have a fantastic
week of shows for you today remember
subscribe free
at youtube.com slash the davidpackman
show I will see you on the bonus show or
tomorrow